hi my name is Terry Andres I am playing
Ariana in limelight okay and Terry how
did you get the role of Ariana and
limelight and the casting director had
just casted me in something and asked me
to put this on tape and I actually
auditioned for Mia and then got ariana
oh ok so different role and then you
were pleasantly surprised with apart
okay and what do you think of today's
social media landscape I know the
subject of the film is a character who's
an actor and that you know narcissism
and that constant self-promotion but it
seems like it's a necessary I don't want
to call you an evil yeah but if there's
there's good and bad to it so yeah what
are your thoughts on it because as an
actress I'm sure that you have a lot of
things you have to do in that realm as
well tweet instagram i think it's real I
think it's hard and it's hard to have to
promote yourself as the product over and
over and I think one big one of the big
things is people do get very much so
almost narcissistic or in their heads
about it which is it's a hard thing to
make somebody try to make themselves
some like the best product and the best
thing the best person that they could
possibly be and like try to sell
themselves over and over and not not
become big-headed i guess or at least
look like it I mean I've lived in LA for
six and a half years and for sure um
you see people fall into that evil into
becoming so self-involved or evolving
into someone they're not because they
think it betters themselves in any which
way and I'm no it's la I feel like or
Hollywood you lose yourself very easily
people
you